turning now to the Border crisis
President Biden taking hits from all
sides I wonder why as his own party
calls out the administration's
immigration policy fails and per haps
the greatest act of hypocrisy AOC
um criticizing the Biden Administration
despite the ongoing search the White
House claims no one's done more to
secure the Border than Joe Biden let's
wire him up to a lie detector uh Gretch
Jenkins joins us live from DC with the
very latest no chance of an actual
polygraph right I don't think so I'll
get back to you on that Steve Rachel and
Brian good morning and Rachel it's a
stunning claim we'll get to that in a
second but first we got some numbers the
number of family units crossing our
Southern border reportedly reaching this
all-time high you see here according to
the Washington Post there were 177
thousand border apprehensions of which
91 000 of those Crossing were part of a
family group now that's more than we've
ever seen before it comes as
congresswoman Alexandria ocasio-cortez
pins the blame on President Biden in the
federal government telling the New York
Times this quote immigration is arguably
this administration's weakest issue this
is one area where our policy is dictated
by politics arguably more so than any
other AOC also calling it a crisis
something that the administration still
refuses to do so despite the
record-shattering numbers we keep seeing
in fact the White House even says
nobody's ever done more on the border
than Joe Biden
the president has done what he can from
from here from the federal government
from the White House to put forth and
manage our border in a safe and humane
way to respect the Dignity of every
human the president has done more to
secure the border and to deal with this
issue of immigration than anybody else
he really really has really because the
numbers are back to record levels we're
getting 7 000 a day now and if you think
about those families coming why aren't
all the families coming sources tell me
it's to avoid x-rated removals that
mostly single adults are facing in the
fat guys that when a family claims
Asylum only one of them has to have a
positive adjudication for the entire
family to be able to stay so they're
trying to strengthen numbers approach
Steve Rachel Brennan and those are the
rules Griff thank you very much for the
live report uh of course the White House
says that this is an actual problem but
they don't blame Joe Biden and the
policy he put in place on the first day
instead they blame the Republicans they
say it's uh it's these political stunts
where they bust the immigrants out of
Texas and send them to places like New
York and Washington and Philadelphia and
Chicago and now Los Angeles as well well
you know what uh now the rest of the
country actually has gotten a taste for
what Texas has been going through for a
very long time which is probably
catching up to it well this is probably
why Alexandria castro-cortez is now
pretending like she didn't like this
open border policy because now it's come
to Brooklyn her own constituents are
really ticked off about how it's
impacting services and conditions in her
own District of course she lives in a
fancy Penthouse in DC most of the time
but here she is if you look at this
picture remember she was outside of a
Detention Center during the Trump
Administration crying she brought her
camera crew of course to capture the
images and
um you know she was so upset about
detentions well there are more
detentions
um here in in more people crossing over
the Border by the way in record Heat
this summer God knows how many people
have died along the way we know that 80
000 children that she claimed to be
crying over because they had been
separated from their parents so that the
Trump Administration could determine if
they were actually their parents indeed
um 80 000 under the Biden Administration
have we have no idea where they are they
have no idea what's happened to them
some of them are in child labor and
slaughterhouses across our country
working in in fast food restaurants
illegally we've seen those kinds of
arrests but we've also we also know that
many have fallen into
child sex trafficking I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis